[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN NURIK: Hello,
and welcome to
Android Design in Action.
This is our first episode
of this brand new show.
My name is Roman Nurik from
the Android Developer
Relations team.
We are broadcasting here
from New York City.
We're also joined by Nick
Butcher, who is, I guess, to
my screen left.
And he's coming from London.
Nick, you want to say hi?
NICK BUTCHER: Hi.
It's me here.
ROMAN NURIK: And we also have
a special guest in the back,
Adam Koch, also from the New
York Android Developer
Relations team, and he's
producing the show today.
He'll be providing some color
commentary here and there as
he sees appropriate.
And yeah, so that's the team
kicking off this very first
Android Design in Action.
Now, I'm guessing many of you
don't really know much about
the show since this is our
first time and we haven't
really talked much about it.
Very briefly, I just want to
talk about a brief history.
So, many of you are already
followers of
the Friday app clinic.
And in that app clinic, some
of our teammates, including
Reto Meyer, Daniel Pham, and Ian
Lewis, they look at apps
that are nominated to the team
through Google Moderator.
They look at those apps, and
they inspect ways in which
they can improve the apps.
They look at what potentially
could be fixed, what the apps
do wrong, things like that.
And so this show is basically a
spin-off show to look at the
design, specifically to look at
the visual and interaction
design aspects of some of these
apps and see how those
can be improved.
So today in this first show,
we're going to look at three
apps from the Friday
app clinic.
We're going to look at the
London Underground app, the
London Bus Checker app,
and m-parking.
And we're going to look at
specific screens from those
apps and look at how we can kind
of reimagine or rework
them to better follow our
guidelines from the Android
design site and, in general,
how to just overall improve
the design of the apps.
So with that, let's
get started.
Let's look at the
very first app.
We're going to switch
to the demo here.
And you could see that we're
using a fancy little setup
using Dropbox, thanks to the
developers of the Dropbox app.
We're going to look at the
very first app, which is
London Underground.
So this is actually one of
the screens from the app.
This is the live information
screen.
You get to this screen from
the top-level one.
There's this little icon.
It's kind of like an exclamation
point that gets
you to the screen.
And it basically tells you the
status, the state of the
different lines on
the Underground.
It gives you things like
access to weather.
If you look down here, it gives
you access to weather at
the very bottom.
And then it also tells you the
current departure boards.
And then it actually even
notices-- and this is
something that I noticed
checking in from New York.
It notices that you are not
actually in London, and it
notices that you are
in New York City.
And it says, hey, we actually
have an app for that.
We have a New York City version
of this app available.
And that leads you to the Play
Store to get that version.
So it's a pretty straightforward
screen.
Nick, do you have any initial
comments on the screen's
usefulness since you are
coming from London?
Do you have any idea on--
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
I feel privileged today doing
two London-based apps with me
here in London.
I think when I look at this
screen you pulled out, the
first thing I think is, it's
fairly iOS styled.
That's my gut reaction when you
have kind of the rounded
white sections.
That's the first thing that
jumps out at me, really.
They have made an attempt to
adopt some things, like we
have an action bar, although
it's using some slightly
non-standard styling there,
which we'll get into later.
But yeah, the first thing
that jumps out
to me is the iOS-ness.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
And you could tell just by, like
you mentioned, the kind
of rounded, grouped list items
and then this gray background.
So, yeah, there's definitely
kind of a styling from a
different platform.
So that's one of the first
things you'll notice that in
the redesign coming up,
one of the first
things that we changed.
The thing that stuck out to me
was there's a lot of space
dedicated here to showing all
the different lines, all the
different lines of the London
Underground, for example, the
Bakerloo, the Central,
the Circle Line.
And all of them have
good service.
So it seems like it's just
showing a lot of information
that's the same.
It's not really useful
information, seeing that
everything is good service.
So if I'm, say, taking the
Waterloo line, you'll notice
here in the second screenshot,
this is kind of the
scrolled-down version.
If you scroll down, then you
have to find Waterloo and then
and only then see that
there's minor delays.
So that was one thing that stuck
out to me, that to see
any actual--
I guess actionable information
about the status of certain
lines, you have to scroll, and
that's never a good thing.
NICK BUTCHER: Also, for me
particularly as a Londoner, if
I'm pulling out this app and
going to the live Information,
it's probably because I'm
heading towards a specific
line and I want to know if
there's anything going on.
So I want that information
first and foremost
right at the top.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so let's talk a
little bit about some of the
other interactional elements.
So the first thing that--
well, one of the
first things that--
one of the second things I guess
that I noticed was that
there's no up button, right?
So this is a subsequent
screen.
So there should be some way
of getting up in the
hierarchy of the app.
So there's an icon here, but
there's no up-caret indicating
that you can go up.
The other thing is that the
action bar has a bold title.
And while that's sometimes OK,
while that's often OK, it's a
little nonstandard.
So it kind of takes away some
of the visual attention from
the content of the screen.
And, also, this is
kind of curious.
There's an update button
somewhere in the middle here.
And really that's probably
something that should be kind
of like a refresh action,
potentially in the action bar.
So with that--
NICK BUTCHER: Do you mind
if I comment here--
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, go ahead.
NICK BUTCHER: On the action bar
icon, it doesn't really
come across in the screenshot,
but the highlight is
nonstandard as well.
So when you touch the icon,
the highlight behind it is
kind of tall and narrow.
There's a very--
nice zoom-in.
There's a very standard size
and shape that you would
expect with these controls,
and that's part of the
importance of the action
bar, that it's very
familiar to the users.
So every time you kind of
deviate from that standard
size and shape, then all of a
sudden, it's introducing like
a cognitive speed bump to the
users, where something just
feels slightly off.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: So it sounds
nit-picky, but I think it
really contributes to
making your app feel
very easy to use.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And the last thing I want to
point out before we jump into
the redesigned version is the
Send Us Feedback link.
Generally, for things that are
secondary, things like
settings or send feedback, or
log out, or things like that,
we generally try to put that
into the action overflow since
that's really what it's for.
It's for actions that users
wouldn't really use on a
regular basis.
So if 10% of the time, even 1%
of the time they're going to
be using Send Us Feedback, you
may want to just come up with
the action real quick.
So moving on, we're running a
little short on time, I guess,
for this part.
Let's jump into the redesign.
So this is a reimagined version
of this screen.
And I'm going to quickly
zoom in here.
So you'll notice that we've
changed some of the colors.
One of the things that we
started with was the dark
action bar theme.
And this isn't something that
you should do for any app, but
it kind of conveys a pretty nice
contrast between actions
and screen content.
Also, we put weather as a second
tab that you can swipe
over to since weather is
potentially something that is
fairly important.
This isn't necessary, but
it is a nice touch.
The other thing you'll notice
here is that we took that list
of all the different lines, the
Circle Line, the Bakerloo
Line, the District Line, and we
collapsed it only into what
the user wants to see,
which is exceptions.
Exceptions to the almost always
well-running London
Underground.
So in this case, you
notice that--
NICK BUTCHER: [CHUCKLES].
ROMAN NURIK: Is that
true, Nick?
Does the Underground actually
run pretty well?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
It's running great.
Underground is running great.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
So right now I'm guessing
that you would see no
exceptions in this tab.
So you see that you Circle Line
is closed, and this is
just an imaginary situation.
If the Circle Line is closed,
there's a little bit of
iconography to indicate that on
top of the yellow color for
the Circle Line.
And then minor delays on the
Waterloo Line, you would see
that below.
And you'll see that we actually
use Holo styling
throughout.
We use these standard list
headings that have this all
caps twelve-SP text.
And then below those two
exceptions, we actually just
say as an additional
confirmation to the user that
all the other lines have
good service on them.
The other thing I will quickly
point out here is that for the
traveling in New York City, I
guess, the toast or pop-up,
that's kind of an exceptional
case that
rarely happens, likely.
So what you may want to do there
is actually just show up
a kind of like a bottom toast or
a bottom bar that slides in
and lets the user take action.
And if they don't really care
about New York City, if I just
happen to actually open the
app in New York City, just
press the X to dismiss
that and never
show it to them again.
So, Nick, with that, do you
have any thoughts on this?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, it
immediately just feels much
more like at home on
my Android device.
It feels like it fits in with
the system look and feel using
the Holo styling.
I especially like the
use of color.
It really made the pertinent
information jump out to me.
The things I care about when I'm
opening the line's status
is what is closed?
What's going to be delaying
my journey?
I think what it needs to be is
where it points to the app
where it pops out to me now,
so that's my favorite
takeaway from that.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
The other quick things we'll
point out before jumping into
the next app is that there's a
refresh button here in the
action bar to convey that
you can refresh
everything on the screen.
And that's the standard place
to put something like a
refresh on Android.
And then for the other piece,
the View Departure boards over
here, we moved that as well
into the action bar
as an icon up top.
Oh, and Adam points
out that we should
probably mention the ad.
So you'll notice that in the
original screen here, there's
an ad at the bottom.
There's nothing really
preventing you from using that
same ad in the bottom here.
The only thing that really would
detract from it is the
traveling in New York
City banner.
But in that case you may want
to consider that's really an
ad for yourself.
That is effectively
a house ad.
So maybe that could cover up--
or if that is the case, if you
are traveling in New York
City, hide the other ads
and show this house ad.
And when you dismiss, maybe
show the other ads.
So that's, I think, it for me.
Nick, any parting thoughts
for London Underground?
NICK BUTCHER: I think just if
you take a look at these two
snapshots next to each other,
you can notice that there's
much less chrome around
the content.
Instead of using bounding boxes
and different background
colors to give the app structure
there, we've used
typography and consistent
spacing to really convey the
same information in a much
cleaner way, which to me makes
the content pop our
much more also.
I think this side by side really
sums up the Holo design
philosophy very nicely.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
All right.
So, with that, let's move
on to the next app.
The next app is m-parking.
And so this app basically--
I don't really know how to use
this app, because I think
parking in the States works
a little differently.
Nick, any thoughts
on m-parking?
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
So here in London, there's a few
schemes like this, where
you can pay for your parking
fee by sending an SMS to a
certain premium number.
And that will-- you basically
SMS them your vehicle
registration plate, and that'll
give you parking for a
period of time.
So this app lets you set up
certain zones which work with
it, with the appropriate SMS
numbers attached to them.
And then you just hit
a button, and
it sends this message.
ROMAN NURIK: Interesting.
So and you've tried this out.
At what point did it actually
send the SMS?
Was it outside of the screen?
NICK BUTCHER: So this screen
we're looking at now is one of
the set ones.
This is where you actually
configure the parking zone,
where you enter in the number
that you need to SMS to and
how long that kind of
covers you for.
So once you've configured this,
then on the very home
screen, it'll show all the zones
you've configured and
the car registration numbers
you've saved.
So the first thing you see when
you open the app is you
just hit one of the zones
you've saved.
And it'll send a message
and basically
give you parking access.
So this is one of the setup
screens you would go through
in configuration.
You have to do this step.
ROMAN NURIK: So basically, you
wouldn't use this on an
everyday basis.
So things like speed, in
general, if you're using
something on an everyday basis,
you want to minimize
the number of inputs.
You want to make it quick and
easy for the user to just fly
through and obviously
not make mistakes.
But this is kind of an auxiliary
screen, right, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I could imagine you probably
install this app and configure
three or four parking zones
which you primarily frequent.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So let's talk about what we
would change in this screen.
So the first thing that jumped
out at me was that
there is a Save icon.
And in general, barring the
whole discussion of whether a
floppy disk is actually a useful
metaphor these days for
Save, there's two ways to
basically leave this screen.
Actually, three ways if you
count the back button as well.
And this is something that I
recently posted about in a
post about the Done button.
We'll talk about that
in a moment.
So, basically here, I can press
Back, or Up, or Save to
basically get out
of this screen.
And it doesn't seem to be a--
it doesn't seem kind of like
a specific affordance for
discarding changes
or reverting.
That's a whole issue
in itself.
But that was the first thing
that stuck out to me, that
there's a lot of ways to save
and get out of this screen.
The other thing is that just
purely from a visual
standpoint, the blue action
bar and the blue screen
content didn't really
mesh well for me.
Generally, in this kind of app,
where you're entering
data, lots of data, you probably
want to use a lighter
background.
I think the darker backgrounds,
like a black or
the Holo dark theme, those are
best used for media apps like
Gallery or playing video.
And so when I'm entering text
or entering data, it seems
like it's a better fit
for a lighter theme.
The darker color action bar, the
blue action bar, is fine
for branding.
But that's just one of the first
things that jumped out.
The second thing was
around visuals.
So you have labels here, like
name, SMS number, price,
things like that.
So the problem there is that
they're not really aligned
with the content itself.
So you have, I'm going to
butcher this, TariffBreak 1
and then the SMS number, and
they're not visually aligned
with the rest of the text.
So that was another thing.
And, lastly, I just wanted to
point out that this color
chooser seems a little
simplistic.
You actually can't tell this
from the screenshot, but the
background color is the
currently selected color.
So if I touch yellow here, it
would actually change the
background color of
that to yellow.
So that's not a very common way
of indicating selection.
So with that, Nick, any thoughts
on this screen?
NICK BUTCHER: No, you've
pretty much nailed it.
I think they've basically taken
the color palette from
the iPhone and run a little
bit too far with it in my
book, especially when they
haven't customized the Holo
control fields, where I find
that the blue underline in the
text boxes doesn't really
contrast highly with the
background color and making
the focus get
lost a little bit.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
And actually, I just want to
make a callout since you
mentioned that, Nick.
Someone-- and I forget your
name, I'm very sorry.
Someone has actually recently
created a generator for
styling, for Holo styling.
So you can just punch in a few
colors and you can generate
all the different assets for
buttons, for text boxes,
things like that.
If this developer wanted to
disregard our feedback about
the light color and wanted to
have a lighter color for the
text field, the little bottom
bar, they could use the Holo.
I think it's called a Holo
style generator.
We'll link to that afterwards.
OK, so let's jump into
the redesign.
So here's a redesigned version
of that screen.
You'll notice immediately that
we switched from using Save
and Up to a single
Done button.
And this mirrors what you would
see in the people app,
for example, on Ice Cream
Sandwich and later.
So when you edit a contact,
you're presented with this
similar screen for
entering data.
The other thing we did here was
that we took the city, the
location, and we used-- and this
is, I think, one of Nick
and my favorite things to do
is turn it into a Roboto
Light-- or actually in
this case, maybe
even a Roboto Thin--
large text to indicate that this
is the current general
vicinity that you're
working with.
The zone you're editing
is in Berlin.
The other thing you'll notice is
that we've realigned all of
these labels.
Actually, we removed the name
label because it's almost
self-explanatory that you're
currently editing this
specific zone.
But we took all the other labels
like SMS number and
period suffix, and we aligned
them with the content.
And this is something that is a
little tricky to do with the
framework currently, but it's
something that you can
actually do correctly
with a couple of
tweaks to your padding.
The other thing is that we
dropped period suffix.
So if you'll notice here, period
suffix was to the right
of SMS number.
And that conveyed-- to me at
least, it conveyed a sense of
sequence, so that the period
suffix is almost the suffix to
the SMS number.
And, again, speaking-- this is
coming from somebody who
doesn't really know how parking
in Europe works, but
it was kind of a weird
connection to make, that
period suffix was after
the SMS number.
So we moved that down
to the bottom.
And then, lastly, we made
this color changer.
I'm going to actually switch
to the next slide.
We had this color changer so
that when you touch it, it
gives you a dropdown of the
different colors you can
choose from.
And then you can select which
color you want to change to.
And it shows a little blue
rectangle around the currently
selected color.
And then it also lets you
discard changes if you select
the action overflow.
It lets you discard changes
that you've made here.
So that's a high-level summary
of what we've done here.
Nick, any thoughts?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Immediately for me, I find the
light theme works very well
for the data entry screens.
It's very easy on the eye to
scan and enter quickly and
just lining everything up.
I mean, it makes this screen
flow a lot more with much
better ribbon.
Like design is going to talk
about grids and patterns and
ribbons and stuff like that,
but basically it just means
line stuff up and use the
standard pattern.
I mean, it's a program
and we can then work
with that in structure.
And it just helps make things
really easy and quick to scan.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think all
of these patterns as well,
like one of the most important
things in this input screen as
well is using the appropriate
input types.
So this is a field you can set
on your edit text to hint to
the system what kind of data
is going to be input.
So you can say it's going
to be a number field
or number of decimals.
Or it's going to be a proper
name, where it might
capitalize every letter.
And I think that's really
critical for making the
screens flow very fast and
making you very productive.
So the developer's not
done too bad a job.
They've set a number of input
types in a couple of the
fields, but not all of them.
So I'd like to see those
used throughout.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, a
very good point.
I do want to just add on one
little point to the line stuff
up point you made there, Nick.
In a recent Google I/O video,
I believe it was Advanced
Design for Engineers, Christian
Robertson, who is
the lead visual designer for
Android, he mentioned this
kind of concept of lining
stuff up as part of the
discussion of a gestalt
principles, or "jestalt"
principles.
I don't know how to
pronounce it.
But that was something that
definitely stuck out.
Line stuff up is a very, very
kind of easy way to make
things instantly look cleaner.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
that's where I
borrowed the line from.
And I just want to
echo, again, the
use of Roboto Light.
Typography can really, really
help give structure and
emphasis to your application,
and I think this is a great
example of setting it like a
header and it really popped
out clearly in that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, totally.
Adam had a point
about discard.
Adam, what was that
point, again?
ADAM KOCH: I was just looking
at the screen.
You've got discard
in there, too.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, yeah.
So Adam was just pointing
out that we also
have discard, right?
So in the previous screen,
there wasn't
really an obvious way--
when you press Back or Up,
it's really up to the
developer to decide
what to do there.
We don't have strong guidance
on whether Up
or Back should save.
It generally should.
In cases where you have really,
really destructive
operations, if Save is a really
destructive operation,
like it posts a tweet or
something, or it posts to the
entire world, you probably
want to have some sort of
confirmation or something.
But having that discard in the
action overflow gives that
extra sense of certainty as to
what that action will do.
So moving on to the last app,
we're going to look at London
Bus Checker.
Actually, Nick, since you're in
London, do you want to just
briefly talk about what this
app will do for you?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So it's an application to find
the nearest bus stop to you
and tell you the routes of
those buses and how long
you'll have to wait until
the next bus arrives.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, awesome.
So it's basically exactly that,
it tells you where--
it's your guide to the bus
system in London, effectively.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
It slides into the system.
When you go to a bus stop, it
tells you, you have five
minutes to the next bus.
But not every stop has that,
but apparently there is
information.
So this app's actually
super-handy around London to
find out how long you're going
to have to wait for a bus.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: So I use it.
I paid for this app.
I bought it.
ROMAN NURIK: So Nick is an
avid user of this app.
So let's see how we can fix
this UI, and not really
necessarily fix, but improve.
So one of the first things that
I notice was that this
map dropdown, and the zooming
is kind of wonky right now.
This map dropdown, this spinner,
is kind of off in its
own place somewhere in the
middle of the action bar.
I don't know if that's
intentional or just because
the logo's really wide.
But that's kind of like
a weird place for it.
Also, the logo here, the
placement of the logo in the
action bar and the blue, I
guess, Holo dark border at the
bottom of the action bar just
seems kind of out of place,
especially in such a visually
rich app like this.
The other thing I'll note is
that these buttons here kind
of have styling from a
different platform.
And you can't see this in the
screenshot, but touching on
the bubble doesn't actually
do anything.
To see the details for that
stop, you have to touch on
this blue button here.
And then this is basically a
shortcut to see the bus route
map for that stuff.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, just one
thing, the bus route is
actually one of the most useful
functions of this
application.
You can walk up to a random
bus stop and hit the route
button and see exactly where
that bus is going to take you.
But I don't know whether it's at
all conveyed, but it's got
it on the left in the bubble
and then repeated in this
action bar at the bottom
with the kind
of three dots connected.
It did this on the screen
route to me.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And the other thing is that,
maybe it's just me, but it
resembles sharing.
So the Share action icon, and
this is something that users
of ICS devices especially are
extremely familiar with Share.
It's used throughout the entire
operating system.
And the icon for Share is
basically this icon with
filled circles and flipped
horizontally.
So it may just kind of convey
that unintentionally.
So that's another thing that
jutted out, was that it just
seems like a version of
Share, but it's not.
It's completely separate.
It's a route map.
NICK BUTCHER: And actually,
they are
straight off another platform.
ROMAN NURIK: The other thing is
that, again, you can't see
this in the screenshot, but the
bottom icons are blurry.
They seem to just be either
MDPI or HDPI resources.
You should really-- and
this is just for
everybody out there.
You should really provide XHDPI
resources for your apps.
Because lots and lots of devices
that are out now and
coming out, they have
XHDPI screens.
So, with that, any parting
thoughts, Nick,
on the current screen?
NICK BUTCHER: No, let's go
straight into the redesign.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So the redesigned
version is here.
You'll notice immediately--
maybe I should just stop
zooming and let the
camera do its trick.
You'll notice that immediately
here, we got rid of the
branding up top.
And this is kind of
controversial.
A lot of folks may think, oh,
but I want my brand to be
visible at all times.
But you have to remember that
this is an application that
users use every day.
If they're launching into your
app, they probably know that
they're using Bus Checker.
So it's not necessarily--
it's not necessary to always
show your brand name.
Sure, you can show an icon.
I mean, if an icon represents
your brand really strongly,
then show it.
In this case, just to me
personally, the icon has a lot
of different things
going on in it.
And so it doesn't seem
like a great
representation of the brand.
And so what we did instead was
we thought maybe let's pick a
strong highlight color, a
strong accent color to
represent the brand better.
In this case, we just chose
a reddish pink.
And you could see that in the
action bar there's kind of
this reddish pink outline
underline.
And then in each of the markers
in the map, it also
uses that color.
We also decided to show some
additional branding in the
background of the tab bar.
So basically, you see
the TFL logo there.
You probably shouldn't use the
TFL logo as-is, but that's
just an example of somewhere
where you can put some sort of
square-like branding.
Additionally, very quickly,
since we're running low on
time, we put the Locate Me
button in-line in the maps
since that's something that
users of Google Maps will be
accustomed to.
We've also simplified some of
the icons at the bottom.
We've changed the icon for the
route map to an actual map.
And this is actually based on
some iconography from--
blanking on his name,
oh my God, Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: Guenther.
ROMAN NURIK: Say again?
ROMAN NURIK: Guenther.
Yes, absolutely, Guenther.
Guenther from Germany.
I feel horrible, Guenther,
if you're watching.
Sorry for forgetting your
name on the spot.
But Guenther has provided
a couple of icons.
I think they're called
androidicons.com or something.
He's provided a bunch of
additional icons in addition
to the action bar icon pack.
And so this is based on
a map down there.
And so this conveys
a map of a route.
You can't really see it in the
icon, but it's got two points
with a route in between.
And then lastly, here, we've
changed this pop-up bubble so
that it uses a styling very
similar to the Maps app.
And touching on the entire
bubble will take you to the
details as opposed to
having this kind of
separate icon here.
And then there's this additional
action button that
takes you to the route map.
So that's a very high-level
redesign.
Nick, any thoughts?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, one of my
favorite changes here is the
use of the overlay action
bar as well.
I think that really-- with the
map application especially, it
really, really stands out, that
you get to see this kind
of a whole larger canvas
across the way.
So I think that works really
well here as well.
ROMAN NURIK: And Adam pointed
this out as well.
So you could see here, what we
did here was we used, not a
black action bar, but I think
it's like a 111 or a 222 hex
color with opacity.
So even setting the opacity to
like 90% and using it like
Nick mentioned in overlay mode,
gives the feeling that
the entire screen is
really your canvas.
The map moves across
the entire screen.
So that definitely helps convey
a sense of content is
in front of you and infinitely
pannable, basically.
OK.
So, it's 11 o'clock.
I think that's it
for this week.
But before we cut off, any
parting thoughts from Nick,
first, and then I'll go after.
NICK BUTCHER: No.
I hope that this format's
working well for everyone.
But I think it's a really good
way to demonstrate a before
and after, a good way to
demonstrate the strengths of
designing for the platform and
how you can really remake your
application to feel right at
home on Android and therefore
feel easier to use it.
So, yeah, I hope you
guys enjoy it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And I just want to
mirror that.
Absolutely, if you do like the
format, definitely provide us
comments, either on the event or
in any of the related posts
on the Google+ page for
Android developers.
And if there's anything you'd
like to see changed or
anything you'd like to see in
the future, added or whatever,
definitely let us know.
Like we mentioned at the
very beginning, this
is a very new show.
So we're still exploring
different ideas, different
ways of getting design
in your hands.
Design in action.
So, let us know and thanks,
everyone, for tuning in.
And we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]